welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons here to break down
episode 5 of She-Hulk for you the
episode we got a better look at Titania
and all her vapid influence her glory
more insight into the real designer
behind the superhero looks and some fun
non-stop Easter eggs also I want to give
a quick shout out to my boy Ray who
fixed my computer in time to write this
breakdown you're a big fan of the
breakdowns and I'm a big fan of you I'm
just gonna call it out I'm obsessed with
She-Hulk and judging by the fact that
you're watching this video I'm gonna
guess you are too well if your obsession
with everybody's favorite Green attorney
at law is just like mine it's bound to
spill over into your wardrobe sooner or
later and I know Jessica why aren't you
wearing your wardrobe I spilled
spaghetti on it but you don't have to
spill spaghetti on it go to the Epic
heroshop.com and we have you covered
latest Obsession number 19 Lady Justice
is available in the shop for a limited
amount of time and if that's not enough
for you epic hero shops got a girl boss
shirt in the same font maybe fans of
She-Hulk will recognize but I think what
we all love about She-Hulk isn't just
the ability to boldly Forge novel legal
presidents in the name of Justice or her
hair or her perfect green skin it's that
in a lot of ways she's the first
personification of Justice itself that's
what the Superhuman law division tea and
sweatshirt are all about Justice is
jacked and remember in the first episode
of She-Hulk when we found out that cap
[ __ ] epic hero shop drop captured
immediately so that fans like us can
show our support for getting some into
the MCU these designs would be rad
enough if they were on posters but you
get to wear them and trust me epic hero
shop stuff is comfy as hell regular
rotation for sure this is the absolute
best way to support the channel and
wearing the merch is the best way to
spot fans in the wild
so make sure to wear it to the Avengers
campus conventions and opening weekend
also be sure to tag at epic hero
shopping news hashtag real epic hero to
get featured on their page get
everything you need to be the stylish
nerd you know you are at Epic
heroshop.com geez Louise we open to a
song called higher written by Mark
Campbell we get the famous pass by
effect this time on a pink screen that
says She-Hulk by Titania Titania has a
new luxury skin care Beauty and wellness
product line named She-Hulk we get the
strong female driven campaign montages
of Titania wearing this 600 dress we
know she's fashionable our girl is
currently at New York Fashion Week I
love the pr She Hulk and Jamila jamill
are doing this is also just giving a
Dove commercial literally all beauty
commercials ever made as Jen drives her
Prius through West Hollywood peep the
Chateau Marmont Hotel signed we see the
giant billboard for Titania's pop up at
the Grove which is a giant Shopping
Center in Los Angeles it's super packed
celebs have been spotted there I guess
from time to time I guess that's the
hype I don't really like it the promo
code strength is beauty gets you 15 off
Titania is very Petty and very much me
Jen is listening to Pro Se law 360's
podcast which is a real weekly podcast
on law 360. law 360 is the overarching
umbrella that covers legal news giving
quick coverage on issues that affect
attorneys Business Leaders and
Regulators Titania fans are also
confirmed called titaniax by Titania on
the radio Chad comes barreling through
Jen's apartment Jen lock your damn door
this is happening so much I'm sure
towards the end of the season we'll get
someone clearly not good strolling after
Chen mansplains trademarking law to Jen
but in reality who's really the smart
one now She-Hulk you couldn't even
trademark it but Chad knows he always
knows we get our title screen this time
it's pink my favorite color and with a
little feminine glow lens flare that was
once the color green but now it's pink
by Titania is incursive at the bottom
instead of its normal attorney at law
the voiceover says she hooked by
titanium thank you down in exactly like
Kim Kardashian just like me I'm sure
it's the added influencer Valley Girl
Vibe overall it's looking like a Titania
episode so let's just get really into it
we're at Titania she pop up the sunset
Arts District I don't think there's a
sunsets Arts District but there's an
actual Arts District in downtown L.A
also how do I get that Titania cardboard
cut out please someone at Marvel at me
and give it to me when Jen noticed the
snake venom lip plumper she says snake
venom lip flower
literally selling snake oil which is a
saying in reference to all those Miracle
elixirs or those fraudulent marketing
schemes people make this place is Wild
on the wall we see TVs featuring Titania
dressed in her Sunburst Crown in space
like a beautiful space goddess and I
hate to be that person but I agree with
Nikki Jen these are all different
products Beauty serum for your face for
aging Beauty oil is usually soften the
skin keep the moisture in and Beauty
tonic is like high in vitamin C usually
good for Plumping I just use a ton of
different products like geology and
Fenty either way we get a look at
Nikki's desk which is very Nicky Ramos
her plaque few office supplies the
Titania lip gloss sample she got earlier
along with this cute mini stack of donut
keychains and dumpster fire toy created
and sold by the head writer Jessica
gal's husband on his website 100 soft it
also comes with a nightlight one I've
gifted these before so I'm really happy
to see this like little call back in my
life pug enters this episode needing
Nikki to stand in line with him for
those damn fine Iron Man 3s we saw in
earlier episodes time and time again
like every Sneakerhead nose you need one
to rock and one to stock baby his guy is
known as Alonso the drip broker now I've
been told the term drip broker exists
but I refuse to use it ever again after
today it's just too silly for me either
way I have fashion program someone that
acts as an intermediary between a
fashion brand and a manufacturer so in
this case the brand being She-Hulk the
manufacturer being Luke Jacobson Alonso
could easily be some random dude but
just how fun would it be if it was Zemo
the man loves fashion and he had an
infomercial on Marvel Studios assembled
about fashion called tsukovia or it
could be 100 soft like they said on
Twitter Cafe bow Bay I might pronounce
that wrong and I'm so sorry the friend
for the superhero clothing business
we've got another QR code that takes you
to the She-Hulk Marvel comic page the
She-Hulk issue number 10. for free and
in a messed up way we learn Nikki can
speak Chinese or at least say we're not
cops in it before we say that this is
Jubilee from X-Men reference it's also
the name for restaurant items and some
famous cleaning supplies so settle down
your Jubilee stands Jessica gals looking
out for her man and I love it I'm very
sure this is made by her husband at 100
soft y'all check them out they're all
super cute they have a collection of
Marvel currently good to also note
everything here is slightly off Avenger
undies and cups that say fur and Hulk
Hulk as Borat beach towel Captain
America shield that resembles the shield
from the 60s Avengers issue number four
but note is not quite the one we're used
to the shirts that say Avengers and
Avengers we see the Avengers mug in the
courtroom illustrations too let's notice
what's off shall we Thor's shovel
instead of a hammer which is hilarious
because they offer Thor's hammer not
only does Hulk have a mustache but the
protruding nipples are a nice touch Iron
Man's colors are backwards also the
error on the chest Hawkeyes has like a
hawk foot bow which I guess you could
make but is not a signature sure we've
got this very cute Captain America but
he has an eagle on his hat chest and
shield the closest we ever got to that
was the wings on the side of his helmet
and black widow has a red scorpion on
her chest also not to mention the arrow
and Avengers is pointing the opposite
direction it normally does an Avengers
this is second hand rape bootleg place
and I love it also the team we never
knew we needed is pug and Nikki I love
them so much though I've talked a lot of
crap about Mallory I respect her
professionalism where she's taking
titanium she helps case as a
professional courtesy I love this line
why didn't you trademark your own
pseudonym and I mentioned it in episode
2 breakdown that Stan Lee had to
trademark She-Hulk quick they created
She-Hulk from the success of the
Incredible Hulk the TV series and with
the bionic woman being so popular it
seemed like a good idea Marvel was
afraid that CVS would introduce a female
version of Hulk so they decided to
publish their own version so if any show
made something similar Marvel would own
the right kind of like Spider Woman it's
just easier to trademark but it got me
thinking yeah what about Hulk Iron Man
Spider-Man Hawkeye do they have to
trademark their names no of course not
because they don't have have Petty
people in their lives like Titania but
I'm also sure Iron Man probably did also
fun fact did you know that the word
superhero was trademarked by Marvel and
DC Comics in the 60s allegedly Marvel
and DC Comics lawyers will leave you
alone if you use it casually and as long
as it stays off the cover you can use it
in comics what I'm just trying to say is
stay on top of your trademarks and also
Marvel please don't come at me for
spreading this knowledge our judge for
today is She-Hulk vs Titania courtroom
Showdown is Judge early played by Mary
Kraft Titania's lawyer is Robert Wallace
played by Darren tunder also I hate that
if you're going to steal someone's name
Titania don't make your product pink and
green that makes no sense we see one
clip where Jen refuses the name She-Hulk
and our second clip is from Bob De
Castro's interview in episode 3 of
She-Hulk we're now at Luke Jacobson's
and if you're like mt you probably
already peep the confused Eugene padelio
Delio that's how Mt says it padillo
Eugene is completely confused walking
out so it must be his first time there I
assume he's picking up the suit for
someone else if that's so he could
potentially be picking up the suit for
his father the OG leak frog in the
comics or for someone else Eugene could
steal the costume that was supposed to
go somewhere else the theories are
endless here but we got a good Glimpse
at mt's boy we're also introduced to
Luke Jacobson played by the amazing
Griffin Matthews Luke Jacobson is a
famous designer from Marvel Comics he
was an award-winning designer in fashion
mobile and he worked alongside Dakota
North appearing in Dakota North comics
in the 80s and the first thing he does
is Scream but not out of fear of
She-Hulk but at her ghastly outfit also
just want to note we've seen Sun
designers in the comics like Leo
zielinski who tailored costumes for the
X-Men Avengers doom and a ton of other
folks then we've got folks like
Spider-Man who made his own original
then got an updated suit from Tony Stark
thorus who was basically as guardian
armor Melvin Potter and Daredevil but
this Loop is the real deal and Edna Mode
of the MCU and I ain't seeing a damn
Cape yet no capes we can see clothes
they're currently working on including
this nice striped sort of 16th century
armored dress but it's also given
slightly an Olympian fighter Vibe this
looks similar to something someone like
Athena or Sif would probably wear just
like a fighter or Warrior type the black
feather one could be for someone with
either exaggerated bur-like features
like beak or just spooky undertones like
sister Grim when we turn around we see
the black head mask piece with black
horns could be for someone it's a wild
Theory like Lilith or magic next to it
we see a gold and green shiny fabric
which sort of reminds me of Jean Gray
and Loki's a straw dress which is insane
in an armored suit with nipples like our
favorite Batman and before you guys come
at me that was a joke nipple Batman is
not my favorite Batman we see Mallory
with Todd from Jen's last date the one
that was calling her a specimen played
by John bass John bass mentioned a d23
Todd is a billionaire playboy
philanthropist douchebag who wants more
than anything to feel like Tony Stark he
is used to getting whatever he wants but
he's a total creep who starts popping up
everywhere this reminds me of Kristoff
in the 2014 She-Hulk run who had a ton
of money was very much a bachelor
Playboy but wanted asylum in the U.S
from latvaria he was Dr Doom's son and
it's very fun run maybe Todd won't be
Kristoff but give the same energy of
demanding She-Hulk to be there for him
or just getting one whatever he wants
like a crybaby like me I think he's also
drinking the really expensive Saratoga
Water which is like 84 dollars for like
three I wish I lived that life when we
take a look at Jen's dating profile her
About Me section says mean green and
straight poured into these jeans which
is the great title of this episode also
Jen was looking to a sturdy back and
reinforced king-sized bed Jen oh my God
and all in front of the men who you met
on the site that is oh this is horrible
also each of their gestures already
reflect the type of people and energy
they give off and I don't like it okay
so we're reintroduced to the four dates
we saw in the last episode Derek the
strong one Noah the director Todd who
we've seen too much of I just don't like
him and Arthur the one she took home now
what Arthur says here about not wanting
to date Jen but wanting to date She-Hulk
can easily be connected to the comics
but also just to be in a human in the
comics Jen was so attached to the
spectacle that was She-Hulk she never
wanted to be Jen Walters because she
wasn't fun or outgoing enough as Jen
this scene hurt me so much because Jen
is Jen She-Hulk is Jen don't want her
getting any warped idea that no one
likes Jen which is something we'll
probably dive into more in the next
coming episodes it's basically like them
just trying to coexist together as Jen
and She-Hulk like banners but obviously
like completely different Titania says
this isn't over and we've seen a new
footage it indeed is not over She-Hulk
will punch her in the face soon we still
haven't got the answer as to why this
whole beef even started but we can bang
on seeing titanium more I don't think
she'll be the big bad of the series but
a speed bump along the way oh that's
offensive to be referred to as a speed
bump in the comics like I said earlier
Jen and Mallory don't get along but I
like the idea of even a weird messy way
she can become friends with Jen who
needs girls versus girls beefing they're
two class A lawyers let's not pit them
against each other uh C'est La Vie we're
back at the legalese bar and on the TV
it's the same anchor from the second
episode for kzyo Jen breaks the fourth
wall talking this time for the first
time this episode when she reminds us
remembering she needs to check out her
new clothes She Hulk arrives at Luke's
to pick up her clothes we can probably
expect to see few fits from the trailers
like this dress that makes her ass
looking amazing for She-Hulk suit and
the new fitted suit there's probably a
bunch of options now and also hold up
Tinsley slow down our boy is making a
new outfit for Daredevil it's the gold
helmet we've seen in the trailers it
will never be forgotten and it's for
pickup this is why Charlie is in La
picking up his new threads okay now I
don't want to spoil anything but if you
do want d23 spoilers boss gives one away
on inside marble they got an exclusive
little teaser if she helped with
Daredevil there I know some of you are
watching this from afar I don't want to
make you sprint from your kitchen to
mute me while I give you spoilers so
just click on over there and you'll get
more insight into the shenanigans that
ensue we close the episode to toe strike
I know I pronounced that wrong but the
song is so good it's called say my name
on the nose we get some new courtroom
illustrations Chad hustling selling
She-Hulk merch now signed by our
She-Hulk Holloway drinking the booty
booster he saw in Santa Monica Boulevard
billboard and checking out his boosted
booty now this is pretty fun Nikki and
pug are checking out what I assume is
the Iron Man 3s we see so many shoes on
this wall and I'm gonna try clicking on
all of them and I'll try to figure it
out Captain America we got Deadpool we
got black panther we got Cyclops Vision
I think this is old school like comic
Vision not our newer Vision the thing
Wolverine I say this is Kate Bishop you
can say Hawkeye I think it's fine frog
man Bishop uh from the X-Men not Kate
Bishop green gobbles AKA The Green
Goblin Captain Marvel Spider-Man Moon
Knight so people are saying here this
could be Gambit because of the Spade but
the colors match Jack of Hearts too well
and he has the connection to She-Hulk in
the comics so I'm leaning personally
Jack of Hearts Falcon Nova Ghost Rider
Doctor Strange the Juggernaut Juggernaut
[ __ ] speed ball there's so many I also
think it's fun to have different
opinions so if you disagree that's fine
that's the cool part about being
different people we can have differences
that's great that's everything I spotted
in the fifth episode of She-Hulk it was
a short episode I think it's the
shortest one they did and there was no
like post credits like teaser so it was
a little bit short and so it was my
little breakdown follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
ball a new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you hello thanks for watching
and remember once we're rocking and ones
for stocking baby
[Music]